[Music]
these boats dude they're all spooky I'm
gonna pick that one over on the street
forty years ago on Halloween night
Michael Myers murdered three people
after that horrific night he was sent
back to the institution in captivity
I have prayed her every night but he
would escape the hell did you do that
for
so I can kill him the bus crashed
Michael Myers escaped he returned to
having filled his home I need to protect
my family you have no security system
Karen you need help
it was really there's no reason we were
supposed to be afraid of the sight I've
been preparing for this for a long time
it is not safe to be on the street
tonight he's here he is a killer but he
will be killed tonight
happy Halloween Michael
[Music]
right
[Music]
Michael's here get downstairs go baby go
[Music]
the boogie man all this hiding all this
preparation it was for nothing
it took priority over your family it
cost you your family if the way I raised
your mother means that she hates me
but then she's prepared for the horse of
this world then I can live with that
say goodbye to Michael and get over it
Michael Mya's is a human being who
killed his sister when he was six years
old and he came after you
we just want to know why we want a
glimpse inside his mind Michael Myers
murdered five people and he's a human
being we need to understand I
transferring him tomorrow seven o'clock
yo he'll be locked away until the end of
his days that's the idea
Laurie we saw him we met with Michael I
showed him the mask it was nothing
no response nothing he won't talk to
anyone never has but I think he might
speak with you
[Applause]
happy Halloween Michael plus he forgot
that he waited for this night he's ready
for me
I waited for him Michael Myers is the
embodiment of pure evil he is ruthless
they relentless for us he's
unpredictable
anyone could be next babysitter murders
40 years to this day Michael
Jamie has a talent but she was born with
it you don't believe in the boogeyman
perfect for the movie I made and now
she's perfect for David Gordon Green's
movie you should this is as good as I've
seen since we've did the first movie it
is intense just brutal testing one two
three
we're on we're here to investigate the
patient's that killed three innocent
teenagers on a Halloween in 1978 he was
shot by his own psychiatrist and taken
into custody that night and spent the
last 40 years in captivity hello Michael
I have something you might like to see
everyone in my family like turns into a
nutcase this time of year
yeah I mean your grandmother is Laurie
Strode she was almost a murder wasn't it
her brother converted all those
babysitters no there was not her brother
that's the main that people made up do
you know that I pray every night that he
would escape hey Belle did you do that
for
so I can kill him the bus crashed
what bus crash Michael escaped
excuse me somebody's in here
[Music]
it's waited for this night he's waited
for me I've waited for him
you don't believe in the boogeyman
my god
you should you close the closet door the
sound of Halloween is so iconic we had
to have his blessing we had to have a
John Carpenter score I think the
original theme sits so comfortably with
the film and its simplicity it's almost
like Jaws you don't need the symphony to
tell you how to feel my father taught me
5/4 time Papa Papa Papa Papa bubble I
thought it would be perfect for the
movie but I listened to his sound tracks
all the time there's nothing better than
driving your car and pretending like
you're at a John Carpenter film
[Music]
I got to play with the original themes
of Halloween
take the original score' and modernize
it with new sounds and new approaches I
got to work with my kids which is a big
joy my life it's cool to be with John
continuing that legacy I don't think you
can have a real Halloween movie without
my dad what we wanted to do is make a
scary movie and that's all we cared
about it is going to scare the [ __ ] out
of you I guarantee it
[Music]